we are learning more this morning about
the missile attack ordered by President
Trump on an air base in Syria US allies
are praising the move while Syria and
Russia denounced it welcome back to CBS
this morning we're of course on top of
this story and there's a new video
overnight that shows the aftermath of
the early morning strike Syrian
officials say at least seven people died
in this attack there were two Navy
destroyers in the Mediterranean that
fired fifty-nine Tomahawk cruise
missiles President Trump says the Syrian
base launched Tuesday's chemical weapons
attack that killed more than 80 people
it is this vital national security
interest of the United States to prevent
and deter the spread and use of deadly
chemical weapons there can be no dispute
that Syria used banned chemical weapons
violated its obligations under the
Chemical Weapons Convention and ignored
the urging of the UN Security Council
CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell was deputy
director of the CIA and CBS News senior
national security analyst Fran Townsend
was homeland security advisor to
President George W Bush good morning and
welcome to both of you Fran let me start
with you what are the implications of
this strike look I think in a single
sentence we saw President Obama draw a
red line we saw President Trump enforce
it last night and that gives him
leverage this has been a horrific
violation of international norms that is
Assad's use of chemical weapons and so
the president acted not only in u.s.
national interests but in the interests
of our regional allies he was with the
king of Jordan clearly was moved both by
the pictures coming out and the the
tremendous threat that this poses to the
stability of Jordan Michael what message
does it send to Assad into the world in
general so he will look at the the
target set right the target set was a
single airbase used
for the chemical weapons attack so the
message is sod we'll take is I cannot
use chemical weapons again he will get
that message this will deter him but we
did not go after regime command and
control so that will also send him a
message that we are not going to try to
force him out militarily so he will he
will read both of those messages is it
risky for him to read it that way
in other words might in fact these
things escalate so that there is a
regime change plan so I think he will
continue to use his conventional forces
to go after his own civilians and to go
after the opposition that killing will
continue and if we want that to stop we
need to put additional pressure on him
France should have done more I mean he's
getting praise from most of the world
secondly getting praise for the way was
executed fast and with secrecy right
look Charlie you know when you talk to
sources inside the administration they
say the driving principle was
proportionality one you didn't want
unnecessary civilian casualties when
what you were doing was retaliating for
the horrific civilian casualties - you
wanted to be careful not to be hitting
other sites look there's six major
airfields we only hit the one from which
they launched this chemical attack
because what you didn't want to do is
hit potential other stockpiles and
caused a plume where the where you
caused the release sarin or chlorine yes
Michael this is a chance for the
Secretary of State to really see what
his relationship with Vladimir Putin is
when he goes to on Tuesday to Moscow
this is gonna be a very important trip
the Russians bear significant
responsibility for what President Assad
has done in Syria to his own people they
bear responsibility for the chemical
attack last week and it's gonna be very
important for Secretary Tillerson to
make that clear to Putin and to make it
clear that his support for Assad has to
stop what determines what the US does
next from here friend Michael - you -
Fran you go first well I look I think
what you're gonna see I know that the
administration is now looking at how
much of the underlying intelligence are
they willing to declassify to allow
Nikki Haley to make the case in the UN
Security Council
we've seen lots of sort of statements of
support from allies and partners around
the world and so the question is not
only is this a u.s. responsibility right
to deal with the the Civil War and the
fallout and the instability it's causing
regionally into our European allies but
what are our partners willing to do now
we need more than statements of support
if we want to change the civil war in
Syria and so I think you're gonna see
sort of the pulling together of the
coalition in the region the Saudis the
Jordanians the Emiratis what are they
willing to do to actually now use this
as a leverage point to turn the tide
there Michael speaking about leverage
what are other ways that the u.s. can
scare Assad additional types of strikes
tactical strikes at his closest assets
the president sent a very strong message
to Assad and to everybody else in the
world you can't use these weapons he
gets very high marks for that he could
get even higher marks that if he uses
this as an opportunity to bring the
world together to put pressure on Assad
to come to the negotiating table and end
the civil war in Syria once and for all
he has an opportunity to do that and I
hope he does it and it has to start in
Moscow next week but you've talked about
perhaps bombing presidential aircraft on
the on the ground his helicopters his
office buildings so Nora that's what I
meant earlier when I said we did not go
after regime command and control targets
we did not go after targets that would
send him a message that he has to go and
I actually think it would have been good
had we done that last night we didn't so
we're gonna have to find other ways to
put pressure on him if this succeeds
because the president constantly refers
to the redline and President Obama if
this succeeds it would one more cause
questions about you have to make sure
you are if you make a statement you're
willing to back it up that's right and I
do think this puts sort of very explicit
pressure now on those we also have
national security issues with the
Iranians who are supporting the Assad
regime the Russians by the way if I was
North Korea
this is the timing of this while
president G is here gives impetus to
that conversation with the Chinese look
we're willing to act alone
that's may not be our preference but we
need you to act with us in this
particular case Michael do you think the
US should wait for other countries to
join in before their additional attacks
against Syria if that is the
conversation one of the one of the the
important successes last night was that
the president acted decisively
he didn't take weeks to try to bring
other people on board that's a message
that is going to be heard not only in
Syria and in the region but as Fran said
around the world I think that's very
important and so I would encourage not
waiting for others to join I would
encourage the president to continue to
act decisively Michael Morell and Fran
Townsend thank you thank you